[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 2022 comenzó casi como un viaje atrás
en el tiempo el protagonismo
internacional volvió a situarse sobre el
antiguo territorio de la extinta unión
soviética un despliegue masivo de tropas
rusas en la frontera con ucrania dio la
bienvenida al año 2022 y el día 6 de
enero se puso en marcha en kazajistán la
primera misión militar de la conocida
como organización del tratado de
seguridad colectiva una especie de otan
encabezada por rusia algo así como la
heredera del pacto de varsovia hablamos
en este caso de un despliegue de unos
2.500 soldados bajo el mando de este
hombre el coronel general ruso andrei
serdiukov el mismo tipo que dirigió las
operaciones militares para apoderarse de
crimea en 2014 y que luego comandó las
fuerzas rusas en siria
entre las tropas enviadas a kazajistán
se encontraban unidades de la
cuadragésimo quinta brigada de las
fuerzas especiales rusas una unidad
famosa por sus operaciones en las
guerras de chechenia por su
participación en la anexión de crimea y
por su intervención en siria unas tropas
que en esta ocasión fueron enviadas
hasta kazajistán para reprimir las
violentas protestas que con la llegada
del nuevo año se desataron en buena
parte del país contra el gobierno del
presidente casi mojo martock ayer
kazajistán queridos amigos es uno de los
países más grandes del mundo en
superficie y un importante actor en la
industria energética mundial para que os
hagáis una idea entre otros muchos
recursos este país cuenta con las décimo
segundas mayores reservas de petróleo y
produce más del 40 por ciento de todo el
uranio que se extrae a nivel mundial
ahora bien qué ocurrió exactamente en
kazajistán porque tuvieron que
intervenir las tropas rusas que explica
el creciente intervencionismo de la
rusia de vladimir putin qué
consecuencias puede tener pues bien
veámoslo pero por cierto un momento
antes de continuar la pandemia del
coronavirus ha puesto sobre la mesa un
nuevo tipo de política económica hoy
conceptos como austeridad o equilibrio
presupuestario han quedado totalmente
excluidos del discurso político y la
pregunta es que está detrás de este
nuevo paradigma económico para responder
a esta pregunta no te pierdas el último
vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido el canal
de actual la financiera de mutuactivos
os dejamos el link abajo en la
descripción dicho ésto continuemos
una plutocracia en llamas
el día 1 de enero el gobierno kazajo
eliminó el control de precios sobre el
glp un combustible mezcla de butano y
propano que en algunas regiones de
kazajistán es muy utilizado por ejemplo
es el combustible que usa la inmensa
mayor parte los automóviles en este país
y claro tras eliminarse el control de
precios el coste del glp para los
kazajos se incrementó de la noche a la
mañana en un 140 por ciento fue algo así
como la gota que colmó el vaso
porque amigos kazajistán es un país que
durante las últimas tres décadas ha
hecho inmensas cantidades de dinero
gracias a todos sus recursos naturales
sí pero sin embargo pese a ello el
estándar de vida general es bastante
reducido el salario medio ronda los 570
dólares al mes la inmensa mayor parte de
los trabajadores ganan mucho menos
amigos durante años en el gobierno de
kazajistán ha convertido al país en una
de las mayores
plutocracias del mundo
[Música]
de qué estamos hablando exactamente
queréis una prueba pues fijaos según
kpmg tan solo 162 personas controlan más
del 55 por ciento de toda la riqueza del
país y no no hablamos ni de
emprendedores ni de empresarios de éxito
la mayoría son parientes amigos o
aliados del antiguo líder nursultán
nazarbáyev una condición que les abrió
de par en par las riquezas del país así
es kazajistán
el caso es que la situación estadio el
día 2 de enero cuando las protestas se
desataron en sanos en una pequeña ciudad
de la era soviética próxima al mar
caspio y desde allí pronto se
extendieron por gran parte del país al
tiempo que del precio del glp se pasó a
una crítica general contra el gobierno
inicialmente las protestas fueron
pacíficas pero de repente y sobre todo
en almaty la principal ciudad del país
las cosas se salieron de madre a las
protestas se unieron grupos mucho más
violentos que no dudaron en enfrentarse
a las fuerzas de seguridad en almaty por
ejemplo prendieron fuego a coches de
policía al ayuntamiento asaltaron
comisarías almacenes intentaron tomar el
aeropuerto e incluso se hicieron con un
montón de armas
hablamos de toda una guerra campal con
un resultado devastador por un lado más
de una docena de policías y miembros de
las fuerzas de seguridad perdieron la
vida por otro las bajas entre los
manifestantes se cuentan por decenas
seguramente incluso por centenas el 9 de
enero del 2022 las autoridades de
kazajistán dicen que hay 164 muertos en
las protestas y que el país ya está
estabilizado unas cifras oficiales que
todo apunta a que se quedan muy lejos de
la realidad
y es que amigos la respuesta del
gobierno fue implacable solicitó la
intervención de las tropas extranjeras
autorizó a las fuerzas de seguridad para
que pudieran disparar a matar sin previo
aviso decretó el estado de alarma el
toque de queda y se ordenó buscar a los
manifestantes casa por casa el
departamento de policía de cinco pisos y
eran una especie de transportador de
tortura los gritos se podían escuchar
desde todas las ventanas las torturas
fueron horribles para ser avise
participante las protestas contra el
gobierno en almaty pero como se llegó a
este punto que buscaban en realidad las
protestas
[Música]
bueno pues hay muchas incógnitas y nadie
tiene del todo claro qué demonios pasó
hipótesis para todos los gustos que si
la cosa se desmadró porque algunos
oligarcas locales quisieron aprovecharse
de las protestas para ganar influencia y
si en realidad fueron aliados de
nazarbáyev quienes estuvieron detrás de
todo que si fue cosa del kremlin que si
fuerzas extranjeras que si fue todo cosa
simplemente de una juventud harta de mal
vivir en un país repleto de riquezas o
quizás una combinación de varias de
estas hipótesis
[Música]
en cualquier caso lo que sí sabemos a
ciencia cierta es que el gobierno del
presidente toca jeff apoyado por rusia
desencadenó una enorme represión y una
gigantesca operación de castigo durante
los días siguientes se calcula que las
autoridades han detenido a más de 10.000
personas eso y que toda esta explosiva
situación ha dejado claros ganadores y
perdedores alguna idea pues fijaos el
primer ganador claro ha sido el propio
presidente toca jr y es que veréis hasta
ahora este presidente que llegó al poder
en 2019 tras la renuncia del histórico
dictador consultando carballés había
tenido en cierta forma que compartir el
poder con él porque aunque si va a
hacerlo ayer renunció formalmente se
aseguró de ser nombrado líder de la
nación y jefe del consejo de seguridad
nacional tocar y pudo poner fin a este
doble poder esquizofrénico en el país
nunca se convirtió en un presidente
plenamente empoderado porque tenía las
manos atadas arcadi luz no fue experto
en asia central sin embargo los
disturbios lo han cambiado todo ha
nombrado un nuevo gobierno que ha cesado
al mismísimo nazarbáyev como jefe del
consejo de seguridad nacional y ha
depurado a muchos aliados y parientes de
esta antigua línea
[Música]
este es por ejemplo el caso de caer
máximos responsables de la agencia de
inteligencia de kazajistán y una de las
manos derechas de nazarbáyev que ha sido
cesado detenido y acusado de traición
otro ejemplo es el de samar avis sobrino
del antiguo líder que fue despedido como
subdirector del principal servicio de
seguridad del país y no sólo eso el
propio presidente también ha culpado en
el parlamento al antiguo líder de crear
un estado oligárquico que ha enriquecido
a unos pocos a costa de la mayoría como
si le estuviera libre de pecado los
disturbios se han convertido en una
oportunidad real de demostrarle a los
kazajos que en casa sólo puede haber un
dueño tokai efe es a día de hoy la
principal figura política del país y la
que toma las decisiones importantes
eduard por la eta el politólogo kazajo
de hecho esto es lo que podría explicar
la propia intervención de las fuerzas
rusas dejar claro a todos los órganos de
poder de kazajistán que tocan jeff es
quien manda y quien tiene el aval y el
respaldo del mismísimo vladimir putin es
decir que despliegue ruso en realidad no
se llevó a cabo para frenar las
protestas sino sobre todo para punto al
actual presidente para tocar importante
mostrar a la gente a las élites de
kazajistán que es la persona por la que
putin está apostando alexander liz mohn
jefe del departamento de política de la
universidad libre de berlín lo que nos
lleva directamente al segundo gran
ganador de esta tormenta vladimir putin
[Música]
y es que veréis hasta ahora kazajistán
trató siempre de mantener un cierto
equilibrio en sus relaciones con rusia
china y eeuu de hecho nazarbáyev abrió
de par en par el país a las grandes
petroleras norteamericanas y también
europeas hoy empresas como chevron
exxonmobil tienen miles y miles de
millones de dólares invertidos en el
país
en términos políticos las relaciones de
nazarbáyev con eeuu fueron siempre por
lo general bastante buenas pero ahora
esa equidistancia se ha roto calle
fechado en brazos de moscú y de vladimir
putin y eso eso es algo que puede marcar
un antes y un después kazajistán es la
segunda mayor economía de las ex
repúblicas soviéticas tras la propia
rusia y ahora la influencia del rey
blind aparece por primera vez casi total
empieza fuerte el 2022 para el líder
ruso por su parte si estos son los
grandes vencedores está claro que
también hay grandes perdedores además
claro está de los propios manifestantes
todo apunta a que a uno de ellos es el
antiguo líder nursultán nazarbáyev y
gran parte de su entorno el otro es
occidente particularmente los eeuu que
de la noche en la mañana puede haber
perdido la mayor parte de su influencia
en el país en favor de moscú un moscú
que últimamente parece no parar de
apuntarse más y más tantos atentos
el coste del imperio
[Música]
rusia ha encontrado un nicho de mercado
en el que su política exterior resulta
imbatible ganar influencia a cambio de
apoyo y de proteger a líderes
autocráticos es algo que ha hecho ya en
síria en bielorrusia en venezuela y
ahora en kazajistán en otros lugares
vladimir putin está logrando lo que hace
unos años parecía casi imposible
recuperar buena parte de la influencia
que antaño teníamos empezando por los
antiguos estados soviéticos no se trata
sólo de apoyar a gobiernos autocráticos
el despliegue de más de 100.000 hombres
en la frontera con ucrania deja muy
frenar las intenciones del kremlin cómo
es que los juegos
[Música]
y ojo no penséis que se trata sólo del
creciente activismo político militar
sino sobre todo de una estrategia que
lleva años ejecutándose durante las
últimas dos décadas vladimir putin ha
modernizado el ejército ha desarrollado
nuevas divisiones de fuerzas especiales
ciberguerra mercenarios y operativos de
inteligencia todo para poder recuperar
la vieja influencia de moscú todo para
que la madera rusia pueda volver a ser
grande
ahora bien un momento porque toda esta
aventura no resulta gratuita tiene un
precio muy alto hablamos de un coste
económico y también estratégico le
explico por un lado sostener este
imperio es algo que resulta muy costoso
todas estas aventuras requieren de un
nivel de gasto cada vez mayor lo que
conlleva de traer recursos de la
sociedad civil para destinarlos a
expandir la influencia del estado esto
es algo que los rusos conocen muy bien
de su experiencia soviética la urss
destino tantos recursos a mantener su
capacidad militar que éstos terminaron
dejando exhaustos a todo el país aun así
perdieron la guerra fría por ejemplo
según datos del pentágono entre
1974 y 1982 la unión soviética produjo
59 veces más misiles balísticos 27 veces
más tanques 7,6 veces más vehículos
blindados el doble de aviones o 2,3
veces más submarinos produjo más de todo
pero no les vale de nada la influencia
de moscú fue efímera y terminó cayendo a
medida que la economía soviética colapsó
ni siquiera tuvieron nunca la sensación
de estar por delante de los
norteamericanos que lideraban la carrera
tecnológica y tenían una capacidad de
inversión en equipos de vanguardia
incomparablemente mayor
[Música]
el excesivo peso que en rusia tiene el
ejército y la política exterior está
haciendo que al mismo tiempo que moscú
recupera su influencia la economía local
y el nivel de vida de los rusos no logra
mejorar el primer ruso medido en dólares
alcanzó su nivel máximo en el año 2013
su dependencia de los recursos naturales
no se ha reducido y las infraestructuras
los hospitales y las escuelas del país
se encuentra en un estado calamitoso y
esto es lo que explica que según las
encuestas realizadas por ejemplo por el
centro levada más del 50 por ciento de
los jóvenes rusos quieran emigrar a otro
país
es decir que rusia ha hecho exactamente
lo contrario a lo que ha hecho china
cuya prioridad durante las últimas
décadas fue claramente la economía pero
eso no es todo la economía rusa también
se está viendo perjudicada por las
sanciones internacionales y las nuevas
incursiones rusas podrían terminar con
nuevas sanciones que la castiguen aún
más y la cuestión es que es más
importante la influencia del estado del
mundo o el nivel de vida de los propios
ciudadanos rusos bueno nosotros lo
tenemos claro y ojo porque son los
propios rusos quienes tampoco parecen
tener dudas
[Música]
según el centro lavada en el 2021 solo
el 32 por ciento de los rusos querían
ver a rusia como una potencia respetada
y temida por otros países el 32 por
ciento es decir a la inmensa mayoría lo
que les preocupa es poder vivir mejor
[Música]
además las últimas acciones rusas
podrían terminar con un final inesperado
el regreso a una carrera armamentística
que rusia no está en disposición de
ganar es decir de tensarse la situación
la otan y sus miembros particularmente
los países de europa del este podrían
determinar blindar la frontera con
niveles de inversión militar récord en
su día esa carrera contribuyó
decisivamente al hundimiento de la unión
soviética y puede que el escenario hoy
no sea muy diferente
[Música]
así que si puede parecernos que podéis
rusia y putin están ganando una partida
y desde luego tienen importantes bazas
por ejemplo la dependencia energética
que la unión europea sigue teniendo de
los eau rouge o la unión europea obtiene
el 41 por ciento de su consumo de gas
natural y el 27 por ciento de su
petróleo de rusia pero a pesar de todo
amigos la historia puede volver a
repetirse en cualquier caso si algo deja
claro la última incursión en kazajistán
es que estamos ante la rusia más fuerte
de las últimas tres décadas pero
llegamos hasta aquí y turno para ti
crees que la influencia del estado tiene
que situarse por encima del nivel de
vida de los ciudadanos piensas que rusia
podrá mantener su influencia
internacional a pesar de una economía
renqueante que cada vez está más lejos
de las otras grandes potencias cómo
crees que los países occidentales deben
lidiar con putin déjanos por aquí abajo
tus respuestas y ahora si este vídeo
tiene resultado interesante no olvides
darle al botón de like i suscribirte a
visual política un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]